again when it comes to things dangerous
on the roadway sometimes motorcycles so
this morning
we're highlighting motorcycle safety the
state's zero fatalities program is
working to prevent more deaths
hectomejia is talking with safety
experts this morning he joins us live
from
a safety course that is happening i
understand some folks have already
started to show up hector
oh yeah that is true good morning to you
bianca we actually have a few people
here
getting ready for their safety course as
we all talk about motorcycle safety
so as you can see right behind me right
harley davidson here by sahara and
rainbow
that class is about to start but first
we want to talk with steve ritchie
manager here at red rock harley davidson
all right so what's going on right now
so this is a new rider course this is
for students that want to get their
motorcycle endorsement
um so they started actually last night
with a
classroom and then they're riding now so
they're getting ready to get on the
motorcycles some of these people it's
their first time on a motorcycle and
you're telling me this is a trend that's
just taking off during these times a lot
of interest happening here with
motorcycles
and they're just about to really learn
the beginning ropes
yeah i call it a motorcycle journey
because everybody's somewhere different
in their riding experience so
this is the start of their journey we're
pretty excited you know because we like
to pass on our
knowledge and our experiences that we've
had as coaches on motorcycles and
it's good to get them started on the
right foot and a safety minded concept
of riding a motorcycle safely
and on that note yeah it's all about
safety preventing injuries and the
deaths yeah it's the training's the
number one thing and making sure the
motorcycle fits you we have fit
specialists here at red rock
harley-davidson that'll actually help
fit a motorcycle for your style of
riding and your size they can make
a thousand different adjustments to seat
heights motorcycle heights handlebars
to make sure that the bike fits you
properly and that's what another big
things that crashes happen people are on
bikes that just don't fit them
and on that note you were just
highlighting this motorcycle here just a
few minutes ago and you were telling me
about some of the features so though for
those watching from home
who may be interested in doing the same
thing what do you want them to know
right now
so these are 20 20 street 500s these are
designed for
training here at harley-davidson so
these are the bikes you'll be riding
they're brand new motorcycles less than
a year old
high quality bikes to ride during your
training then you can actually graduate
after you graduate the class you might
want to move up to harley's newest 2021
that is beautiful that's the pan america
it just came out here in 2021
it's their adventure touring motorcycle
we are lucky enough to have a few of
them here at the store
that uh they're not everywhere in the
country they're that new to
harley-davidson and harley's put a lot
of technology a lot of information into
that newer bike
it's pretty neat thank you for having us
so early in the morning
so again the uh motorcycles are becoming
more popular among women
this group here we have women over to
the left
and even more women over here to the
right they're about to go through the
safety course and
learn how to ride a motorcycle for the
first time ever and lastly
we're highlighting this because
according to zero fatalities
motorcycle fatalities actually went up
this year by 30 percent
all across the state so we're talking
about safety and making sure everyone
is safe on the roads reporting live this
morning hector mejia
8 news now back to you guys